hello I am Jessica McDonald it's the
20th of March you're tuned into gamespot
news and I was definitely trying to
throw you off by using my whole name so
we talked about project Morpheus already
but let's get you updated on what you
can expect from it then ft head mounted
display will not be coming to the market
in 2014 because according to sony it's
not that far along in development in a
similar blow we have no idea when the
consumer version of the oculus rift will
be released either PlayStation president
of worldwide studios Shuhei Yoshida has
however speculated on the price for
project Morpheus saying the customers
won't have to spend a thousand dollars
to get their hands on it let me know in
the comments how much you would pay for
a virtual reality device as for more
details on titanfall 2 according to a
source the game will not be max off
platform exclusive EA may have landed
the rights to the lucrative sequel but
sources have told polygon that it
doesn't necessarily mean that the series
will remain Microsoft platform exclusive
this sits pretty closely in line with
what has been suggested by respawns
Vince Zampella previously that the dev
team did intend to make a ps4 game and
that it just wouldn't be the first
titanfall metal gear solid 5 ground
zeroes has earned itself a censored
version for its Japanese iteration do
cover your ears now if you're concerned
about hearing any details about the game
seriously I'll just wait just go watch
cat videos or something alright so
series creator Hideo Kojima told weekly
Famitsu that the Japanese video game
ratings board made the ruling but it's
not clear which scene has been affected
we already know that the game includes
fairly graphic depictions of torture so
one could suppose that that could be the
scene in question lastly Peter Molyneux
has told everybody to keep an eye on
Nintendo just as no one ever expects the
Spanish Inquisition Molyneux has told
IGN to never underestimate Nintendo the
fable creator has said that the company
is probably one hardware release away
from something which in his words
utterly convinces us that they know
exactly what the future of games should
be whilst morn you did say that he isn't
a fan of the clunky Wii U design he
thinks that the developers staff are
super smart even if
did sort of lose their way with the
controversial hardware let me know in
the comments if you reckon Molyneux is
right or if you think this is the
beginning of the end for Nintendo you
can also drop me your thoughts on my
Twitter where I'm at Jess McDonald or
send me a picture of yourself watching
this very video that is it for me today
but tomorrow I'm giving you my top five
stories of the week so I hope to see you
again then